tratemos de restar 301 164 los animo a
que pasen el vídeo y que traten de hacer
esto por ustedes mismos
vamos posición por posición y nos damos
cuenta que tenemos que hacer
reagrupamiento o pedir prestado en la
posición de las unidades tenemos un
problema 4 es mayor que 1 así que como
vamos a restar un número grande de uno
pequeño y tenemos la misma situación en
la posición de las decenas 6 es mayor
que 0 como podríamos restarle 6 a 0 y la
respuesta tal vez ya lo han pensado es
reagrupar o pedir prestado pero nos
encontramos con otro problema decimos
bueno está bien tengo este uno y pedirle
prestado a las decenas una decena y
tendré 11 pero en las decenas no hay
nada entonces que hacemos lo que vamos a
hacer es pedir prestado primero para las
decenas voy a reagrupar 100 de la
posición de las antenas es como pedir
prestado 100 a la posición de las
centenas y aquí me va a quedar 2 y en la
posición de las
escenas en lugar de este 0 voy a tener
10 y vamos a asegurarnos de que esto
tiene sentido este es dos centenas más
pies decenas y decenas es igual a 100
más 1 esto es 200 más 100 más 1 que es
igual a 301 así que está funcionando
esto es muy útil porque ahora puedo
reagrupar desde la posición o el lugar
de las escenas si tomo una decena para
reagrupar en las unidades aquí me quedan
9 decenas y 10 más uno es igual a 11 y
podemos verificar que el valor del
número que tenemos no ha cambiado 200
más 90 es igual a 290 más 11 sigue
siendo igual a 301 hicimos todo esto
porque ahora cada número es mayor que el
correspondiente que tenemos abajo en
cada posición y ahora estamos listos
para restar 11 menos 4 11 menos 4 es
igual a 7
96 es igual a tres y dos menos uno es
igual a uno y el resultado es 137